[Musique]
ayasse sofia sainte-sophie perles
d'istanbul et joyau du patrimoine
mondial
inauguré en 537 par l'empereur byzantin
justinien c'est un des plus vieux
bâtiments sur terre encore utilisé
aujourd'hui
d'abord la plus grande basilique qui
m'ont chrétiens elle devient mosquée en
1453 quand les ottomans conc'air la
ville et que byzance devient
constantinople
l'extérieur est impressionnant mais
l'intérieur est encore plus majestueux
une immersion dans mille cinq cents ans
d'histoire et d'art sacré où se côtoient
le christianisme et l'islam
je marche aussi avant ce mur aussi
existait mais il y avait 1 comment un
commandant byzantin qui arrive de la
halle aux projections qui vient de
l'autre côté jean costes mails et guide
à istanbul depuis 27 ans il nous parle
de la fameuse coupole 4e plus haute au
monde qui culmine à 56 m sans doute
l'élément le plus remarquable de
sainte-sophie juste en dessous les
quatre anges explique-t-il protège le
paradis tant aux yeux des musulmans que
des chrétiens c'est le président veut
écouter de légende ça peut durer une
semaine parce qu'il ya juste deux sens
les jantes qu'on raconte pour sa survie
et mai
sainte-sophie était un musée depuis 1934
mais en juillet 2020 à la suite d'une
décision du président turc recep tayyip
erdogan le site a été reconverti en
mosquée
l'histoire a créé plus de controverses à
l'international compte turquie où 99 %
des pratiquants sont musulmans
mais croyez moi beaucoup de nos frères
chrétiens viennent nous visiter et ils
voient que sainte sophie est un lieu de
prière universelle nous prions pour la
paix la fraternité
je n'ai entendu aucun chrétien se
plaindre les visiteurs doivent
maintenant retirer leurs chaussures
avant d'entrer dans la nef où le sol est
désormais recouvert d'un immense tapis
bleu seule une petite partie du plancher
d'origine en marbre est encore visible
[Musique]
à l'intérieur les tours guidés côtoient
dans tous ceux qui choisissent un coin
pour se recueillir
avant les arabes et les musulmans du
maghreb par exemple ne visitez pas sain
et sauf et maintenant et visites
cinq fois par jour lors des prières
quotidiennes des musulmans les touristes
sont interdits mais comme l'islam exclu
l'art figuratif des mosquées certaines
mosaïques chrétiennes sont cachés par
des rideaux
nous en prenons soin sont importantes à
nos yeux on les couvre seulement pendant
la prière dans le respect de nos
croyances ils étaient des centaines ce
jour-là à s'être déplacés pour la grande
prière du vendredi
ce qui n'avait plus de place pouvait
prier sur des tapis installés à
l'extérieur
se représente notre histoire l' empire
ottoman la force des musulmans et de nos
martyrs
l'unesco rendra publique en juin un
rapport sur l'état de sainte-sophie
nombreux s'inquiète et espère plus
d'argent de l'état turc pour la
restaurer pour qu'elle demeure aussi
encore longtemps ce lieu de rencontre
unique entre les peuples et les
religions
[Musique]